we're here with the 2023 Blitz World
Champion Magnus Carlson this is your
fourth time winning the Blitz and the
rapid in the same year how do you feel
I'm relieved I'm exhausted as well um it
was not an easy day um at all I felt
that I was just you know running on
adrenaline the whole day and um but on
the other hand like everybody is
struggling I think towards the end um
nobody is really playing their best so
it was just about surviving one game
game at a time and um yeah I'm happy I
made it lots of chest we saw you walking
around a bit listening to music by
yourself did that Solitude and peace
help to get your mind clear yeah I think
definitely the fresh air helped quite a
bit also it was a sunny day so I thought
I should um be outside a little yeah
take take advantage how do you get
energized the Sun